i had two goals setting out on this
expedition
one was to be the first person to ride
the entire length of the ho chi minh
trail
the second was a personal goal and that
was to find the place where my dad's
plane went down in 1972.
[Music]
blood road is sort of a slang name for
the ho chi minh trail and the ho chi
minh trail was the supply route used
during the vietnam war for
the north vietnamese to supply arms and
troops towards the south
the whole route was about 1200 miles
from top to bottom it's the longest ride
i've ever done
completely unknown territory
my dad served in the vietnam war and he
was shot down in 1972
i was just three years old when he died
so i don't have any of my own personal
memories of him
i was looking for a way to get to know
him a man that i never knew and
physically going to the place and
connecting by bicycle was really the
only way i knew how
the train was
a total mixed bag from pavement in the
cities to using a machete
plenty of times we had to put our bikes
on the shoulders and carry them up and
over a mountain but i will say the
physical part of the journey wasn't the
most challenging part of the journey for
me for me it really was
opening up emotionally and being
vulnerable
[Music]
there's a huge trench as far as i can
see just dug down where the plane slid
[Music]
it was the first time in my life that i
felt
my dad's presence i felt close to him
and i felt like he was there and the
first time in my life i felt like i
could stop chasing something and i could
just sit and be in that moment
as a professional athlete i'm trained to
be strong and independent and show no
weakness
it took me by surprise that it impacted
me that much
[Music]
you